we all wanted to know what it was like
to go to the moon we're explorers I
think it's in our DNA there's nothing
that beats the moon landing the moon
landing is the greatest accomplishment
it's the gold standard for doing
something incredibly hard we're full
steam ahead for Apollo you good with
that engine start the vehicle actually
moves and sways just a little bit and
when it comes back to straight vertical
the solid rocket boosters fire we're
sending our hopes and dreams on this
machine and shooting them off the planet
one of the strongest emotions is
standing there on the ground watching
people you know launch I just saw how
incredibly beautiful our planet Earth is
you know that there are billions of
people down there but really I was only
thinking about one of them that was my
wife they did some pretty amazing things
with some pretty basic technology NASA's
motto should be making even impossible
things look easy and Apollo 11 was just
one of those very first points where we
proved it's not impossible
you
you
you